la foire de beaucroissant a vécu en ce
qui concerne du moins son édition 1969
et pour la 750e fois environ ses fastes
ont attiré la grande foule des
connaisseurs et des badauds le nylon a
peut être remplacer la toile de voiron
et la musique électronique celle de
l'orgue de barbarie
mais la beaucroissant comme on l'appelle
là-bas a gardé son caractère de plus
grand spectacle de france chacun il
retombe un peu en enfance les plus
petits font des tours de chevaux de bois
sous la surveillance des parents et
leurs aînés dans le grand tourbillon
tentent d'apercevoir au milieu de la
foule les oies et les dindons heureux
présage des prochains réveillons